Hello and welcome to this video on example number three, customizing editor on startup.
So back in the engine and for this we are on slide nine, example three, startup scripts.
So all we're looking here is another trigger point and this is for us to tie
code to the startup of the engine. Now in order to do this what we need to do is we need to come up
and go project settings and I'm going to search for python. So we have the python script here.
Now what's interesting is we haven't actually looked at the plugin and the options which were
available to us yet realistically. There are only a couple which I think are quite important. We've
got the python pip install in case you want to use that. We've got enable remote execution as
well something I've already tried. But here is the button for isolate the interpreter environment.
So without this it's going to be able to look elsewhere for the python and we've got an option
here to add additional paths so we can manually add paths into the project. But what we've also
got above this is startup scripts and these are scripts which we can we can get the editor
to run at the point that it starts up. Now I only have one script in at the moment and
what this would do is it fires up the teaching aid. So the editor utility widget which I've
created that allows us to move through the project. I wanted this to start up as people start
up the project and I couldn't force that. So the only way I've been able to do it is by using
python to fire that up. You can see that we have that here under we are load asset teaching aid
and spawn and register the tab here. So this is a good example of what you might use startup for.
However in our example I'm going to do something a little bit more complicated with the startup.
What we're going to do is we're going to add some functionality to the editor itself.
So we're going to change how the editor is set up. So if I come back into the main lesson
I have this node here and in the details panel I've got a big script so I'm just going to copy
and paste this. So I select all and copy that. I'm then going to jump into the project settings
and I will paste this in here. Now because this is on startup in order for us to see this
we are going to have to tell it to restart. And now the engine is fired back up again.
So what's different? Well the first thing is at the top here you can see that we have a python
and this has a couple of different options in it. So drop down you can see that open code
folder. What this will do is it will open up my code folder for my python. So just a quick
and easy way of opening that up and the other one is going to fire up the web page. So this
will fire up our our web page for the API. So and this is an example we can have numerous
different sort of settings here but it's creating our own drop down. We have also added in and
we'll look at this later we've added in an option to the add interface here. Python task
selections at the bottom. So this has allowed me to edit the menu system that we've got.
So let's jump back into the project settings and have a look at that script.
It might be a little bit hard to see you might want to go away and have a look at it yourself
but what we're doing is we are creating extra menus. So we are at an extra menu sort of
settings within python. It's a little bit complicated to explain but it's well worth going over
over this. So do have a look at that in your own time. So now if we were to have a bit of a
closer look at at these scripts one of the things that I think is important here is we have
how we define where our menus are set. So you can see we have an option here to extend menu.
We have to provide it with a menu. So content browser, asset content menu. Now getting this
isn't an obvious thing. So if you want to find and add a section into one of these
menus you're going to need to know how to get hold of these values. So let's go through
that quickly. So to do that I'm going to actually use a command here a CVAL so
console command. So I'm going to convert back to the console command and I'm going to type in and
it is toolmenus.edit1 and as soon as I turn that on you can see that we get these cogs
that appear next to each of the different menus. So if I look here you can see we have
content browser, asset content menu. So if we compare that to our script,
content browser, asset content menu. So you can see that's what I want to extend. So
I can now get hold of it. I've right-hand clicked and I can copy a reference to that or
I could come in and edit. Now these appear everywhere. If you look through all of them
you're going to see they appear at the top. So it's nice and a quick way to get hold of
any of these different menus. But that's how you figure out what the reference value is.
You can come in and edit these menus. So here it is from the slides so you can just see it a
little bit clearly. That is how we get hold of these different references. Now it's worth
noting before we get off of this topic that you don't have to place it in the startup.
Unreal is actually going to search for the file initunreal.py in any of the paths that are
available to it and run that at startup as well. So if you don't want to have to edit it
from the project settings you would just want to dump something into the project files. That's a
good way to do it. And that's everything for example number three, customizing editor on
startup. In the next video we'll be jumping into example four.